i'm russian some obviously also khabib
fan
but i'm also a conor fan it seems like
there's not many of us who are like fans
of both
right um what are your thoughts
the two of us which also is a good play
uh
uh stop dude yeah really really tough
dude
there's like five languages really
interesting cat also oh wow i didn't
know that side of it so
there's a brain there well on the khabib
versus conor what do you make of their
first fight
what do you do you agree with me that uh
they should fight again
because i think it would be awesome if
they fought again in moscow
and uh do you agree with me i'm just
gonna put
say things that piss people off but i
believe is that conor actually has a
chance to beat khabib
one the connor absolutely has a chance
to be conor has a chance to beat anyone
that he steps into that ring with and
not just like a mathematical chance you
were like oh one of the billion but like
you know
like he absolutely it's funny because i
i won't pretend to know connor really
well but i first met connor in 2010 when
i was teaching a seminar in uh at
straight bless jim ireland in dublin
um and that's actually where i first met
all of the coaches that ended up being
on
conor's team um you know john cavanaugh
owen roddy uh gunnar nelson you know so
for i actually
i enjoyed being on ultimate fighter and
being on a uriah favors team and getting
to train with all the guys there but at
the same time
the people that i was actually i knew
better were actually the european side
all the connors coaches
um and uh that was a neat thing because
i got to
i met connor i didn't know who connor
like conor wasn't conor at that point
yeah that was before
his ufc oh yeah well well before yeah i
think i think he got in like 2014 maybe
something like that
yeah and uh anyway but he was doing well
in cage warriors winning the titles
there i think prior to that
you know i remember going seeing him on
the show and uh
also then getting to see him train
because i competed uh
i was initially slated to fight david
tamer for the ultimate fighter finale
before getting put into fight artem
for the uh title for the show so i went
over to ireland to train for a couple
days
and basically it was neat to watch him
watch him work i mean
man is focused and trains a lot it's
very very smart
and very very hard working and i think a
lot of times people get stuck in the uh
in this um you know and they
almost want to believe that this was
lucky or this this person
you know they're not working that hard
they're just out there they got there
with their mouth
and that's that's just not the case and
um you know i don't know what it's like
you know obviously connor's very well
off right now and i don't know how hard
how serious he's training what he's
doing i can't speak to any of that
but uh there's no question that he has
skills to be dangerous and
one of the funny things obviously the
khabib fight went could be his way cuz
he was a great fighter and
and also has the chance to beat anyone
in that ring at any given time
but uh there's there was a conor you
know it's uh
one that he can he can put anybody away
and as you mentioned i think that he
doesn't get the credit for the eddie
alvarez fight he doesn't get the credit
for the jose aldo fight because it was
almost so much of a letdown i remember
that happened the same weekend that i
did the ultimate fighter finale
and you're like oh wait what
yeah it almost doesn't feel like a fight
happened but we mentioned miyamoto
musashi i mean musashi was famous for
the way he poked and prodded at people
with what he was doing whether overtly
or not it's like oh we're supposed to
fight to the death and uh you know
at 3 pm tomorrow great
4 p.m rolls around i'm just not there
five i mean you remember all the all the
antics and nonsense that conor was
pulling prior to that like
speaking personally that's not it's not
something i would feel comfortable doing
but it's like everyone's different
and the effect that it had on on jose
was i mean beyond evidence when was the
last time jose
started the start of the fight with
leaping left hand leaping right-hander
like
wait what and then he was obviously
you know living rent-free in jose's head
at that point
and that was a combination of
psychological
you know ability and and wherewithal and
then physical and remind me of the way
muhammad ali would would bother people
and whatnot and
uh the fact that he's a polarizing
figure
um i i think makes some people not give
him his due and then at the same time
sometimes
certain fans maybe go overboard but uh
they remember the knee that
ben askren got knocked out with by
mazdal i mean that was an amazing
unbelievable thing but
three inches to the right three inches
to the left i guess whichever side his
head wasn't
could have been square but uh and that
fight starts with ben askren on top of
you in the first five seconds
well connor ran and threw a knee just
like that at khabib and could be
got right around it that could have
easily gone the other way can you
imagine what would have happened if
after
after coming back from boxing um after
coming back from from the mayweather
fight
connor connor in the first ten seconds
it's over and you're like
he would yeah it would have been
intolerable
but basically yeah like you know but see
here's the thing let me actually push
back slightly uh
i mean to the fans correct me if i'm
wrong
but conor seems to because i've competed
a lot and
like there's attention there's a
negativity sometimes depending on the
opponent
and there's a respect afterwards that
happens like when you understand
that there's a deep like respect and
almost like love for each other
like i always seen that in conor like
all the trash talk
afterwards yes there's a it's it's a
subtle thing
you can't always see it but there's a
respect like i agree
and the like that i almost on the khabib
side
i almost feel like khabib really took it
personally
he did he didn't he lost the respect for
connor i
thought the whole time conor had the
respect so i i what i want to say is
like
if conor won that fight like rock khabib
i could see
like i wouldn't see trash talking
i could see like trash i can stop right
there i think so too but at the same
time
i'm sure you recall like conor kind of
crossing some pretty personal territory
you know both religiously and and also
familiar with uh with khabib and it's
you know i mean i think it's the sort of
thing that i don't know it's it's an
interesting that's one of the reasons
like you have to know the difference so
obviously i know the
the the kibbe the dagestani people they
don't
play around like that they don't play
around with that you know
i mean they take offense to basically i
mean you you don't do that
so uh so like conor didn't
maybe he did on purpose or maybe he
wasn't even just aware of
of uh it was cultural differences out of
the box he opened
like you can talk to him if uh floyd
mayweather
you can you can go anywhere with him you
can you could say the most defensive
things but
with uh yeah it could be it's hard
yeah hard lines
you